hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar next
generation ultra high content analysis
of the tumor immune micro environment
using mix technology i am michelle
ashton
of labyrinth and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotek
to learn more visit miltonibiotech.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask and question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the
process to obtain your credit i now
present today's speaker
stefan euliss the global customer
relations manager at milton biotech
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen the fun you
may now begin your presentation
welcome
thank you for your participation in this
webinar um today i would like to show
you
the next generation of ultra high
content analysis using the mix
technology
to demonstrate the unique capabilities
of the mix technology i would like to
give you some nice insights into the
composition of the tumor immune micro
environment
this structure is a perfect example to
explain why it is really important to
have the most detailed analysis possible
due to its complexity and variability
but let's start with a short
introduction to the topic
solid tumor is embedded in the
surrounding structures of its location
the complex system of different cell
types the extracellular matrix molecules
such as chemokines cytokines micrornas
and other factors as well as vessels
define the specific tumor
microenvironment
even by just looking at all the involved
immune cells which are composing the
specific tumor immune environment
it becomes clear that the
characterization of all the cell types
needs many proteins to be analyzed
one important proportion of the cell
types involved are of course the immune
cells as they provide us with important
information on for example prognosis and
therapy
of the individual cancer the composition
and spatial distribution of these cells
define the tumor immune microenvironment
it can be classified based on the
composition and the infiltrating cells
as well as the state of inflammatory
response
if a tumor is populated with immune
cells but the tumor core is relatively
void of cytotoxic lymphocytes
the time is classified as infiltrated
excluded
which is shown in figure a we will have
an example of this type later in the
presentation
a second type is the infiltrated
inflamed type depicted in figure b
this type is characterized by an
abundance of pdl1 expression on tumor
and myeloid cells and highly activated
cytotoxic lymphocytes
expressing among others p1 and
interferon gamma
the presence of a tertiary lymphoid
structure short tls
adjacent to the tumor defines the third
type the infiltrated tls type
a tls is an aggregation of immune cells
with a similar composition as lymph
nodes
including b cells dendritic cells and
regulatory t
cells we will also have an example of
this type in the presentation
given the complexity and different types
of the tumor immune microenvironment and
also the tumor microenvironment as a
whole
the question arises how can this
structure optimally be analyzed
so what do we need so first of all
we need to visualize a lot of different
structures cell types and subpopulations
so this requires the possibility to
stain a large number of markers
to illustrate that so for example you
want to detect
all different tumor cells and stromal
cells including immune cells
which obviously already requires many
markers furthermore
in order to get a comprehensive
understanding of the involved cells it
is wanted to analyze
as many markers as possible to not miss
an important characteristic of certain
cells
therefore the number of markers should
be even increased
and we have not yet addressed markers we
need to visualize the tissue
architecture
so it becomes very clear that a really
large number
of markers is needed
in addition to the cellular composition
of the time it is also important to
understand the interaction of cells and
surroundings which require information
on the spatial distribution of the cells
and tissue architecture
for this it is necessary to have a
technology
which has not only cellular but
subcellular resolution
as the intracellular localization of
proteins
which means localization the nucleus in
the cytoplasm
at the membrane etc will give you
information on
for example the activation status and so
on
light microscopy techniques are very
well suited to fulfill this requirement
but standard microscopic approaches
usually suffer from the limitation
that the number of markers which can
simultaneously be analyzed is too
limited
to really provide detailed phenotypes of
all involved cell types and structures
the solution for this is the mix
technology and the maxima instrument
and i will explain to you why
the term mix means maxima imaging cyclic
staining technology
and this describes the approach of
iterative cyclic staining processes as
opposed to conventional single staining
methods
this technology overcomes the
conventional limitation in the number of
markers which can be analyzed
and i will give you an explanation of
the process on the next slide
this way of data acquisition is executed
by the maxima instrument
and only by the maxima instrument as
there are several aspects which make the
mix technology and the maximum
instrument unique compared to other
existing cyclic staining methods
the mix technology uses conventional
immunofluorescent stainings to visualize
markers and the maxima is equipped with
a fully automated epifluorescence
microscope inside
which provides the resolution needed to
understand the composition
and structure of for example the tumor
immune microenvironment
let me shortly explain the process and
what you will get as
a result
so first the maxima will start with a
staining step
the resulting immunofluorescence signal
is acquired
and then the signal will be erased
after that the next cycle will start
again
with the staining step
followed by the image acquisition
and the erasure of the signal
it is important to note that only the
markers will be stained in a cycle
which are supposed to be imaged in the
respective cycle
this has some advantages to prevent
steric hindrance
but it is also much easier for
generating image stacks with more than
100 or
couple of hundred markers finally you
will end up with a large and unique
image stack
but this is not the only advantage of
the maxima
the maxima instrument is part of a
complete imaging platform which enables
you to analyze hundreds of markers on a
single sample
in a fully automated fashion which means
apart from loading the samples and the
reagents
no manual steps are involved after
starting an experiment
furthermore all necessary components to
perform such experiments will be
provided
for example sample carriers antibodies
and also analysis software
i would like to mention here that the
maxima platform is an
open platform with regards to antibodies
which means that you are not dependent
on the antibodies
miltoni biotech is providing although we
have a huge portfolio of high quality
recombinant antibodies
indeed we have the largest antibody
portfolio compared to all other
multiplexing technologies on the market
this complete platform solution
therefore opens up such complex analyses
to a very broad spectrum of users as the
technical hurdles are really low
it is also very flexible as it can
handle any kind of fixed samples such as
tissues adherence cells or suspension
cells
the preparation of the samples is almost
not different to the current methods
and therefore does not require laborious
and complicated steps resulting in
really an effortless
experiment preparation another good
message for you
the maximum imaging platform is readily
available now
which means if you are immediately
interested you can simply buy it
but let me convince you about the
technology first
so let's look at some images
the topic for today is the
characterization of the tumor immune
micro environment
and as mentioned before this is a
perfect application to demonstrate the
need for the mix technology
and the maxima imaging platform there
are two main aspects i would like to
focus on today
first i would like to show you a
tertiary lymphoid structure
afterwards i will characterize the
different immune cells on a specific
type of a tumor immune
microenvironment
so let's start with the tls and the
short introduction
the tertiary lymphoid structure is
described here in further detail
in this schematic representation to
better understand the following images
so it shows the tls
and it is located within tumor with a
cd3 positive t cell zone containing
dendritic cell lysosome associated
membrane glycoprotein
short dc lamp dendritic cells
fibroblastic reticular cells and
a cd20 positive b cell zone
with a germinal center plasma cells
antibodies forming
immune complexes with tumor antigens and
follicular
dendritic cells so the coordinated
actions of
cd8 positive cytotoxic factor t cells
and b cells generated in the tls enable
in z to tumor destruction via direct
tumor cell killing for example
antibody dependent cellular set toxicity
mediated by macrophages and or natural
killer cells
and local complement activation
so central memory t and b cells
generated in tls's
circulate and protect against metastasis
and in some cancers
tls is located in inflamed regions
adjacent to a tumor
may also serve as a niche for tumor cell
progenitors or tumor cells
that drive relapse so it is a really
important structure to better understand
tumor and today i would like to show you
a tls in an ovarian cancer sample which
we have analyzed within total 96 markers
so what can be seen in the data
here you see the first ovarian cancer
sample which i would like to show you
today
you see the tumor tissue represented by
the epchem signal in green and the
associated leukocytes marked by a cd45
in red
the nuclei are depicted in blue and
vessels are shown by the cd31 signal
the massive accumulation of leukocytes
adjacent to the tumor
already indicates that this could be
atls
so let's have a closer look at the real
composition of the structure and whether
we can prove this assumption
in this image you see the distribution
of b cells in this structure
and indeed we have a b cell zone
indicated by the cd20 signal
which is already mentioned as
characteristic of a tls
the next cell type we would need to see
are the t cells
this is the staining of t cells with cd3
depicted in light blue
and we can see that many of the
leukocytes are actually t
cells now we need to see which type of t
cells we have here
here you see the two major
subpopulations of t cells
the cd4 t cells which are the main
population here
are depicted in blue and cd8 positive t
cells are shown in red
we can see that both types of t cells
are present in the tls
as expected but we can see that the cd8
cells are also within the tumor tissue
if we have a look at the very right
tumor part
in this image we can have a look at the
proliferating cells which is shown in
white by the ka67 signal
we can see that we have proliferating
cells in the tls but also within the
tumor
another cell type which is missing but
expected in a tls are plasma cells
so plasma cells we have here detected
with cd138 in white
and cd38 in red we can see that we have
some few plasma cells in the tls
but many others have also infiltrated
the tumor area
by the way this seems to be associated
with a better prognosis in ovarian
cancer
so now we have already b cells plasma
cells
different type of t cells but there's
another cell type missing which is
essential for the tls
these are the dendritic cells
in this image you see the dendritic
cells represented by the cd86 staining
in orange we can see the zone where we
have dc's located
it has been stated that these cells
should also express dc lamp or cd
208
so the cd 208 or dc lamp marker
can be seen here in light blue we can
see that not
all of the cd86 positive cells are also
expressing dc lamp
which could also be expected as it is
almost exclusively expressed on mature
dcs
what you can also identify is that the
dc lamp signal is not localized at the
cellular membrane but more in the
cytoplasmic region
this is also as expected since the
protein is mainly localized within the
lysosomes
this is a good example to prove that the
previously mentioned requirement on and
capability of
the maxima instrument providing
subcellular resolution
is true so since dc lamp also plays a
key role in the processing and
presentation of antigens
this staining gives us the hint that the
presentation of tumor antigens is also
taking place in these regions
the staining of hldr here visualized in
violet
is proving the existence of mhc class 2
receptors which is also in line with the
schematic representation of the tls
shown in the beginning
so one cell type which is not part of
the tls but
of the tumor microenvironment are
myeloid cells these cells are shown here
in yellow by the staying of
cd14
the staining of cd 163 and why it shows
us here that
several of the cd14 positive cells are
tumor-associated macrophages
we have now seen the major immune cell
types important to define the tls but
i would also like to share with you an
example which demonstrates that the
findings do not have to be restricted to
the identification of certain cell types
so here you can see mika 79
in red and this is a marker for high
endothelial venules
here abbreviated as hev
i would also like to show you again the
cd31 staining of vessels from the
beginning
here in blue instead of white and as you
can see
not all vessels express mega 79 and are
agvs
to conclude this part i share with you
this overlay of seven markers
illustrating the architecture of the tls
which we could identify and prove due to
the numerous markers stained using the
mixed technology
and the maxima
so let's move to the next example i
would like to show you
today which includes also many findings
from the last years and proves the power
of the technology
since you can see all these great work
done in the past just in one experiment
you will now see a second ovarian cancer
sample where we have characterized the
tumor immune microenvironment
as said this is another sample of
ovarian cancer
and as already done for the first sample
the tumor is here depicted in green
leukocytes are depicted in red vessels
in white
and nuclei in blue additionally
also fibroblasts are depicted in blue
it is immediately striking that the cd45
positive cells are mainly localized in
the invasive margin of the tumor
and not in the tumor core this could
show us that we have a tumor type of the
infiltrated excluded type
but let's look closer at the phenotypes
of the cells
in this image you can see the plasma
cells in white
represented by the cd38 signal and these
cells
are also located in the invasive margin
and absent from the tumor
as could already expected from the
initial stainings
so here in magenta we see the t cells
and these cells are mainly localized in
the invasive margin
and almost completely absent from the
tumor core
this underlines the assumption that this
tumor is of the infiltrated excluded
type
but let's see the different populations
of the
t cells
so when we take a closer look at the t
cell populations and their localization
it is even more obvious that cytotoxic t
cells are not in the tumor but stuck in
the tumor or margin indicated
by the cd8 standing in red
the few cd3 positive signals within the
tumor core are only cd4 positive
so the myeloid cells are also mainly
located in the tumor margin
but some cd14 signal in yellow can also
be detected in the tumor core
as you can see here in the picture
also granulocytes can be detected in the
tumor
here represented in light blue by the
c15 signal
so here you can see all the cell types
in one image which have already been
described and this supports the
designation of the infiltrated excluded
type so in this picture the macrophages
are missing
but since they play an important role we
will take a closer look at them
so tumor-associated macrophages are a
critical component of the tumor
microenvironment
since they can affect growth
angiogenesis
immune regulation metastasis and
chemoresistance
so macrophages are shown here in red by
the cd68 signal together with a cd14
signal inside
we can identify two different
localizations in the tumor margin
and within the core it is known that
most of the macrophages gather in the
leading edge and
vascular areas others can align along
the ab
luminal side of the vessels so let's see
whether we can also see
something like this
so here you see macrophages in red and
vessels in white indeed some of the
macrophages
seem to be located along the vessel in
the tumor core
and in the tumor margin
so in an attempt to further characterize
the phenotype
we see here cd 163 in light blue
which is a molecule on macrophages
involved in clearance and endocytosis of
hemoglobin heptoglobin complexes
furthermore this molecule is mainly
present on m2 macrophages
we can see here that there are already
different macrophage phenotypes present
as not all are positive for
163
so in this picture you can see a cd 206
which is depicted in yellow this is
another marker present on
m2 macrophages which could also serve as
a prognostic marker
as not all macrophages are cd 206
positive
it is quite obvious that we have here
different subpopulations of macrophages
i will not go into more details
regarding the macrophages
and their phenotypes as this would go
beyond the scope of this webinar
since this topic would justify an own
one
but i hope that i could present to you
two nice examples
which give you a flavor of the
technological capabilities of the mix
technology
and the maxima instrument and of course
also the potential for your research
although we have seen more markers on
one sample than possible
with conventional technologies we are
not really close
to the full potential of the mix
technology
therefore i would like to give you a
quick insight into what
else is possible apart from just nice
images
so i will now illustrate the data
workflow of how it would be if you were
characterizing the tumor immune micro
environment with a mixed technology in
your lab so
everything would start with the data
acquisition done by the maxima
instrument
and this is then of course done in the
cyclic staining process
and then you would obtain an image stack
of the markers you have used
especially in the beginning of a project
you would most probably start with a
hundred or
even more markers in order to start the
project as unbiased as possible
as any non-stain marker would be
self-chosen limitation
since the maxima can image hundreds of
markers there is no technological
limit existing
so after the quality control of the
images you can then start
with the segmentation of the images
this can be done with our analysis
software which is
qri tissue or with any other software
you are using
as the images are available in an omi
tiff format
after that you can extract the data and
this allows you to go much
deeper into the analysis
and for this i would like to give you
now a first impression
so here you see a third sample of an
ovarian cancer
and in this case um this sample has been
analyzed with 98 markers
i hope that the transmission of the
video is good
so that you can see all the marker
images
it is obvious that there are many
different staining patterns
and regions of different composition and
this can be immediately identified
having the potential of also including
markers which are supposed to be
negative on the sample is also a huge
asset of the mixed technology
as you are not really limited in the
number of markers
this is also a very good opportunity to
verify existing assumptions in an easy
and comprehensive way nevertheless
such data sets are complex and need some
initial orientation
in order to help you to get an overview
i will briefly show you the composition
of the sample with the most important
markers
as you have already seen for the other
sample examples
so as you can see here the tumor area
is again indicated in red i'm using the
epchem signal
and the leukocytes are shown in red
the vessels can be seen in white and
fibroblast and violet and the nuclei
in blue we see very well that
there are a lot of leukocytes adjacent
to the tumor
and it is of course worth spending
another look
and a deeper look on the sample
so as you can see here the tumor
microenvironment
is composed of course of different
immune cell types as expected
so in this case these are predominantly
myeloid cells
indicated by the cd14 signal
here in blue and also the t
cells represented by the cd3 signal
in red but also we see some
plasma cells which are indicated
by cd38 positive and cd 138
positive cells
so here in this example we see some
other cell types so the
tumor microenvironment is not only
consisting of t
cells and myeloid cells but we can also
see
some natural killer cells shown by the
cd56 signal in red
and also some regulatory c4 positive
regulatory t cells um which are here
shown with the signal of cd25
in blue also some
very few dendritic cells represented by
the
cd1c signal can be positive
so now you have gained at least a first
overview on these cell types we can find
here in the sample
but when we look at the markers we have
shown
these were only 12 markers but as you
could see in the beginning
we have stained many many more markers
so in order to be able to analyze this
i will show you the next necessary steps
here
so the next necessary step is of course
the image segmentation and here
you can see the segmentation mask of
this image
and in this we could identify in total
4425 cells
so the segmentation can be carried out
by
different ways so you can use our qa
tissue software
but also any other algorithm can be
applied
as these images are available as omittiv
files
and therefore accessible for any kind of
analysis software as mentioned before
so segmentation is the prerequisite for
data extraction and this is then opening
up the opportunity to analyze the data
set as a whole
so when you have extracted the data
there are many different ways to analyze
it
you can use our qr tissue software but
since the data table can also be
exported
any type of analysis is possible
so here the result of one option is
depicted
so in this case the cells were first
hierarchically clustered
which is not shown here and then the
main groups of cells
were determined based on the expression
patterns and given a color
after that the dataset was visualized in
a disney plot
so what we can see here is that we find
all the major groups of cells which were
also shown
in the overlay images in the beginning
but
there are also some unclassified cells
which might need a closer look and could
bear
some striking findings
but this is of course just the surface
of the whole information in the data set
as we have clustered based on 98 markers
so furthermore the x and y coordinates
are available
and therefore the localization of each
cell
is also known and this can also be
depicted
in the image this also enables the
analysis of
interactions distances etc which could
also provide useful insights
into the biology
this should just be an outlook what can
be done
and we will show more like this in the
near future therefore
have a look at our coming webinars in
order not to miss
any information about it
we are now at the end of the
presentation
but i hope i could show you the
capabilities and
potential of the mixed technology and
that
is absolutely amazing to have so many
findings
in just one experiment
if you are interested in more
information about the mix technology and
the maximum imaging platform do not
hesitate to contact us
via our websites or sales reps in the
field
and again the good news is that the
maximum imaging platform
is now available for buying
so with this i would like to thank you
for your attention and i hope that you
have enjoyed
the webinar furthermore i would also
like to thank our teams in research and
development for their hard work and i'm
now happy to answer all your questions
yeah okay get your butt inside
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for all right let's go
ahead
and get started so your first question
what should be the thickness of section
yeah so basically uh since this is an
epi fluorescence microscope
the thinner the better so um depending
on the type of
fixation uh you can start with maybe
three microns going up to
ten um so on average we are using five
micron slides
great thanks so much now is it possible
to analyze
full tissue section or only region of
interest
yes it's definitely possible to analyze
full image full slides that's not a
problem
of course these are huge data sets so
you have to handle those data but
technically this is not
a problem of course such runs are taking
a bit longer
but there's no limitation in terms of
regions of interest so whole
slides can be analyzed
thank you can we use any other desirable
marker
yes as i mentioned in the presentation
um
the platform is an open platform
regarding the antibodies
so they are just some prerequisites to
consider
you need primary conjugates of an
antibody
so that means we need in this case
primary antibodies coupled to a flu
chrome and
these flu chromes would have to be
bleachable because this is one of our
erase mechanisms we are using and
therefore
this is something you have to obtain
but if you have this this is not a
problem
you can simply use any kind of antibody
you have
and generate a conjugate out of it and
that's it
great thanks so much now this next
question
i saw you know a few times how long does
it take on
average a staining and imaging cycle
yeah so here multiple factors are
of course contributing to the cycle time
of course the size of the region of
interest is important
but i can say that so the shortest
cycle will be roughly
30 minutes maybe some minutes more
but this can go up to several hours if
you are for example
analyzing a whole mouse brain or
something like
this so this is the range you
can expect
great thank you okay let's see
our next question is the presentation
did not include antigen staining that
requires antigen retrieval
is mixed compatible with antigen
retrieval
yes so you can use basically
all kind of fixed tissues so
fpe tissue which involves such an
antigen
a retrieval protocol and here the most
important thing is that
all the antibodies you want to use are
compatible
with the retrieval method you are using
so you are not obliged to use just one
if you can make sure and test whether
the antibodies you want to use
are compatible with this method you can
use it
so our antibody portfolio has been
tested on the retrieval method
using tech buffer ph9
and heat antigen retrieval so for this
protocol we can tell you which
antibodies from us
are working but that doesn't mean that
this is the only protocol you can use
so yes the mix technology and the maxima
instrument are compatible
with fixation methods needing
antigen retrieval
thank you now this next question says
what is the manual logistics
and loading or preparing 100 antibodies
for use
on the mixed platform to be utilized all
100
and the second part says can it store
the number of stock antibodies for later
staining workflows
so basically for this you would have to
prepare
a 96 um deep well plate which we are
using
for the as a reagent carrier
um so you will simply pipette these
antibodies into
those welds and that's basically it
but if you want to skip this step you
can also
purchase from us ready to use place
the rear screen plate and then you can
even skip this
process um or this process step and this
is then
really almost without any uh needed
preparation
so you have full flexibility generating
your own
plates or using our ready to use plates
but it's not
really complicated it's just pipetting
antibodies into
a 96 well plate
thank you we're receiving such great
questions from the audience now this
next one is a two-part question
how are the colors distinguished and how
reliable
are the acquisitions
so we are user using filters of course
for excitation
and then also for emissions so we are
separating um the signals this way
and the colors you have seen are of
course artificial colors um we are just
detecting grayscale so we have optimized
our filter settings um
to basically be able to image the entire
spectrum but for now we are starting
with three fluorochromes fixed pe and
apc
thank you now a reminder to our audience
any questions that we do not get to
today will be addressed
by safari via email following the
webcast
let's go ahead and move on to our next
question
is data analysis going to be challenging
here
the simple answer is yes on the other
hand there are nice tools
to do so so our um
analysis software qa tissue um is really
making your life much easier there
because um it is optimized for
visualizing such kind of data sets and
also analyzing so
you will have the option to segment the
cells um
the picture you have seen is also
generated
with this platform and this software
and then after segmentation of course
it also offers some analysis algorithms
like
disney plots and k-means clusterings
and this will of course also evolve over
time so yes
analysis is challenging but the tools we
are providing
are also making your life much easier so
that you can
handle these data sets quite well
this is a great question what is the
distinction between
your platform and other multiplex
platforms such as
multiomics on the market
yeah so the the major differentiator
here
is of course the number of markers we
can stain
so as i mentioned in the presentation
we can go up to hundreds of markers
which is mainly due to the fact that we
have a very
mild process of erasing
these signals so that we can obtain
several hundred marker images this is
not a problem
and this is this is the main
differentiator but there are also some
some other details which are different
um so the way we erase
um the signal for example um and
um also the antibodies we are using
um is this is also a bit different and
um i think the fact that we are offering
a full package so you can get everything
from us
of course you have the option to add
something to this but you can get
everything from us
so you don't have to worry that you have
to
solve a problem or something like this
it's really
um i wouldn't say plug and play but it
is really an easy solution for everybody
stefan can you tell us how to how you
erase the stain and signal
yes so um basically we are using two
different methods
uh one method which i already mentioned
um
with a question of the antibodies from a
third party
we are using bleaching this is
a very nice tool because
we have optimized this bleaching we have
a dedicated bleaching unit in our system
um so this offers us also the um the
option to
open the platform also for other
antibodies
but there's a second one which is our
new erase mechanism and which is even
more gentle to the sample than our
bleaching and this is based on
miltoni biotech's realist technology
so we are calling this rear dialyse
because this
is a controlled release of the flu
chrome
we are using specialized antibodies for
this and
this is even as i already said
more gentle and especially for large
samples also
faster and this is the erase mechanism
of the future
thanks so much next question is this
method restricted to particular tissue
types
or can it be used for any tissue type
so you can use it for basically any
tissue type
so we have tested basically any uh
kind of solid tissue
tumors and so on and so forth the most
important thing is
it is only restricted to fixed
specimen yeah so you have to fix it
either with for example pfa
or acetone or as i already mentioned fpe
and therefore you can basically analyze
everything but not only tissue
you can also analyze adherent cells or
also suspension cells for this we are
also offering
a solution so that you can have
a single cell analysis on suspension
cells
thank you now how do you compensate for
autofluorescence
yeah so um here we have a nice advantage
so after um or prior to
a new cycle we are
acquiring um images uh which we can
then use as a background and are
subtracted from
um the marker image and with this we can
um
approach the problem of autofluorescence
so you can also
image tissues which are usually
suffering from a lot of auto
fluorescence for example the liver
tissue because this subtraction
offers you still the dynamic range
which is basically the difference
between
the um the the
potential of the camera and the signal
intensity of the order fluorescence and
with this
you get very nice results also with
tissues
having high odd fluorescence signals
wonderful thank you now is it possible
to rule out the possibility of cross
reactivity
of various antibodies
yeah so we have here some process
related advantages
so if you were staining um
several uh tens or maybe 20
40 antibodies simultaneously i would say
yeah
there is quite some risk that there is
some interaction or competition between
those antibodies
since we are just staining every
antibody
in the cycle which we want to acquire
only in this cycle and not
directly in the beginning we do not have
faced such an issue the only thing i can
say
is if you are imaging markers with a
competing epitope
so an overlapping epitope in let's say
the next cycle
there you can see that there is a
blockage
of the epitope because the antibody is
still on the sample
but if you stain this antibody with the
overlapping epitope in a later cycle
this is possible because the antibody
will detach
because of the washing steps and so on
and so forth and therefore
for us and our technology this is not a
problem
great thank you can we identify
intracellular
markers yes
so an important point here is to mention
i mean if we're analyzing tissue slices
of course
and they are fixed so the fixation
method is also
generating holes into the membrane and
so on and so forth
so yes you can see them but you have to
be careful
if you would like to visualize soluble
factors
make sure that you are using a fixation
method
which is cross-linking these molecules
so you should not use acetone fixation
for example for those vectors but rather
psa for example or ffpe and then you can
definitely image those
those markers
thank you all right your next question
is
can we process paraffin section or
cryosection
compulsory to utilize this imaging
system
so um so the the processing of the
sample
is of course done outside of the maxima
so the maxima is
performing every step fully automated
but
the sample has to be processed outside
so yes
you can process these samples frozen
sections
paraffin embedded sections you just
perform the processing step outside of
the maxima
and then put these samples into the
maxima
and then the maxima imaging platform is
doing everything for you fully automated
thank you now can we quantify chills
sorry can you repeat that
sure your question says can we quantify
tills yes you can
quantify tumor infiltrating leukocytes
because you can
first of all easily identify them
because you can stain a lot of markers
so therefore you can really be sure that
these are tumor infiltrating leukocytes
and the resolution is of course a
standard epifluorescence resolution and
therefore yes
you can
wonderful thank you so much we are
receiving so many great questions from
the audience
now let's go ahead and jump over to this
one and it says
can one converted imaging data to a
statistical data
be used to compare for instance a
carcinoma
to an acquired resistance form of the
same carcinoma
so yes you can extract of course after
segmentation
of the sample which is a prerequisite
here um
to have let's say all cells identified
you can extract the data
here and then uh all statistical options
are
open uh to you yeah so therefore yes you
can
do this and use every kind of
statistical method
you need to answer your question
now how many markers can you view per
round
so at the moment the number of markers
is three per cycle plus the darpy
signal but i have to mention
that the optical bench some the
microscope
of the maxima is already equipped to
cover the entire spectrum that means um
there will be new fluorochromes coming
out especially with the new
erase mechanism based on our release
technology
and there you will get new fluores which
do not need to be bleached and here we
will cover
in the future the entire spectrum so
this number will
increase
now how do you fix the tissues for
staining protocol do you recommend
any particular reagent
so basically we have tested our entire
antibody portfolio on
three different fixation methods the
ffpe
with the epitope retrieval protocol
based on ph9 tech buffer and heat
pfa and also acetone fixation
so if i uh have to recommend
you a fixation method that is of course
very much dependent on the application
um as i already said soluble factors if
you want to analyze those
you have to use a cross-linking fixation
method
but it is also dependent let's say on
the antibodies
and the specificities you need and the
availability of antibodies if i have
all the antibodies available which i
need for a certain fixation method but
for the others not
maybe then you would go rather with this
fixation method where you have the
antibodies
if you still can visualize what you need
to know
thanks so much stefan we have time for a
few more questions
your next question how much antibody is
used
per round per marker
that depends of course on the size of
your sample
so um we are offering different sample
carriers
for standard microscope slides so
we are offering maxwell disposables
with four chambers two chambers in one
chamber um depending
on the size of your um
[Music]
of your sample you can expect costs
between
three euros up to 20 euros per
antibody
great thank you and what is the
processing time
per staining
so we are using here um an incubation
time of 10 minutes
um and then several washing steps and
this
results in the end let's say in the in a
minimum cycle time of
30 minutes but then of course the
the size of the region of interest is
then determining
how long a cycle would be
thank you now is it possible to utilize
cocktails of antibodies in a single
staining and
imaging cycle
yes this is actually what we are doing
because we are
staining um three up to three
markers per cycle and in the future
as i said this will be increasing
so therefore yes you can do that
thank you now is it possible to take dic
or bright field images and parallel in
each case
um unfortunately this is not possible so
the
maxima does not have let's say a bright
field image
or cannot generate bright field images
what is of course
always used and acquired is the
derby signal so the nuclear signal
so therefore this is something you can
always
use also as a control whether
for example the image acquisition has
worked properly
thank you and we have time for just a
couple more questions
what is the maximum maximum number of
markers you can use with this technology
yeah so basically i cannot tell you
because we haven't reached the limit yet
so as i said a couple of hundred markers
is possible
this is what we have done but
since at that time when we started this
uh
we didn't have more than uh 400 markers
i cannot tell you um whether you can
stay in a couple of hundred more
because we simply didn't have more so
of course i have to say here that this
is
also dependent on the tissue you are
using
so not every tissue will survive
400 antibodies or 200 but what i can say
all the tissues we have checked so far
are
definitely able um to um uh
survive um more than hundred markers
um on a um on this specimen
therefore yeah i'm curious to find out
what is
exactly the limit um so yeah stay tuned
also in the future
um we will let you know where we think
is the limit
thank you so much and let's go ahead and
wrap up with this final question
how do you make sure that the images
from the different cycles
are properly overlaid
so as i already said we are acquiring
the derby signal
every cycle and this is what we are
using to properly overlay
um the images and therefore you can
be sure that you will end up
with a nicely registered image stack
after the experiment
so this is basically our technological
advantage
to have one marker in every cycle
thank you so much stefan do you have any
final comments
for our audience before we go today
yeah so um i hope yeah i could provide
you further insights into the technology
with my answers
today um and yeah let me just tell you
that um today we have just touched the
surface
of what is possible with the mix
technology and the maximum imaging
platform
i mean with this technology we are now
entering into a phase
where we will much better understand
nature's complexity
and of course in addition um we will be
able to answer questions
which we did not know that they existed
therefore
there's much more to come and again
watch out for our next webinars and our
web page and contact
us if you want to know more about this
platform and the possibilities
related to this technology and yeah i
simply
thank for your participation and yeah i
will enjoy
seeing you next time
thank you again stefan for your time
today and for your research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their questions as a reminder
any questions we did not get to today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live
event until next time goodbye